antes de dark souls y el del ring estaba
Ninja Gaiden No solamente uno de los
juegos más difíciles que hay sino
también uno de los más geniales y hoy te
vengo a recordar esta joya con algunos
de sus datos curiosos en cierta zona del
juego Si usas tus habilidades de parkour
correctamente podrás encontrar un e eg
en homenaje a Xbox la espada de madera
es el arma más débil del juego pues no
tiene filo y pues es de madera pero si
la mejoras al máximo de repente se
convertirá en el arma más fuerte del
juego teniendo una habilidad en la cual
si tu salud está baja su daño aumentará
al 150 por. lo que en pocas palabras
quiere decir que le romperá la madre a
quien sea en dos o tres golpes si al
completar el juego hemos reunido todos
los escarabajos dorados escondidos a lo
largo de todo el mapa desbloquearemos el
juego original de Ninja Gaiden para la
nes el juego original de Ninja Gaiden
era tan difícil que luego de muchas
quejas sus creadores incluyeron un modo
fácil a modo de burla llamado perro y